alright the big controversy the big
outrage this week is that we're always
outraged are you outright the second
outraged I am constantly outraged
average machine it's endless so the big
outrage in controversy this week is that
NBC News Brian Williams the nightly news
anchor he has retracted a statement he
had said that in 2003 he was in Iraq and
his helicopter got hit by an RPG
apparently he completely made it up yeah
why maybe he started buying his own liar
it started with the kernel of truth is
like but now it's turned out to be
completely false and now he's getting a
lot of heat people on him fired lot of
heat yeah and it is trending on twitter
too what if it's trending on Twitter you
know this is sarah and stuff but it was
making me think we've all lied right
you've lied in your life right forget
the public jacqueline glad I mean that's
a human being I know yes I mean yes yes
we've all lied for different reasons for
different things fine but I was thinking
as as public people as youtubers
babbling on as we do babbling have you
ever lied to those people right there
have you ever done a video where you
were lying and I wanna know the truth oh
I can't so can I lie about like no oh
I'll know if you do I I don't think that
I can think of something that I've like
blatantly lied about because my videos
normally I don't like go into personal
things so much I talk about topics and
relate myself to those topics so I
haven't really felt a need to lie about
things but I have been wrong in videos
before that's even worse than lying you
yeah I have been wrong so I mean I feel
like what kind of thing have you been
wrong about for example well I started
making videos on YouTube as a Christian
so I would talk about what religious
thing yeah hey the early one wait they
had don't look him up Jacqueline atheist
yeah world renowned a penis yeah you
were making videos as a Christmas
average of that was the crust videos not
as a Christian I wasn't like promoting
jeebus or anything like that but I was
like is still in two equal rights and
stuff so I'd be like I believe in
marriage equality and as a Christian
this is how I justify it totally like
making up stuff and ignoring you know
Bible verses that clearly didn't agree
with my position but you know yeah so
I've been been wrong before and I've
changed my position and I evolved as a
person
you can see that happen on YouTube yeah
so you know sometimes people are wrong
and you got to give them a little bit of
leeway yeah I mean I say it all the time
so I don't think that I've ever why I
can't think of an instance where I know
me I well no no it's like my personal
okay you know family and things like
that I wasn't the closet for a long time
that involves a lot of like or trickery
or shenanigans or honey but in terms of
what I everything I've done
professionally I can't think of a time
where I've looked in the camera or
looked at a guess and lied about how i
feel about psych now have I been wrong
I'm sure I've been wrong many times
we've I say it on the show a lot like
I'm happy to be corrected I don't know
about everything about everything yeah
I'm sure between you and Cara Santa
Maria you guys had fact-checked me or
Cara certainly on science stuff which I
muck up all the time because we live in
a time where everyone has to pretend
they know it yeah and that's really
frustrating for me too to see because
like we're human beings we're not robots
we're not like you know some Google
machine that gets every fact right all
the time and people freak out in the
comments if you get something wrong it's
like cool I'll learn from that next time
but they're like jerks about it they're
like yo more on you idiot never make
another video again yeah you're wrong
it's not it's more more than that it's
that they think you're intentionally
misleading them I feel like that should
be that's a big one yeah and then I'll
respond then I'll be like oh well
actually I did a little research or
someone to link me to something and then
I'll tweet now be like yeah I heard that
one up or you know this map was wrong or
something or something like that but I
don't think I've lied outright but so
what do you think the the fallout should
be so this is a pretty respectable guy
Brian was right yeah really
well-respected mean NBC News like he
lied and just a repeat repeated life so
what do you think what do you think you
it sucks because you know there's
credibility at stake here now the
network has to worry about what they're
gonna look like he's probably lost a lot
of credibility but you know like overall
like his job is to report on things
outside of himself yeah you can't really
make that stuff up and the news in
general the networks themselves lie all
of the time you know so I'd give him a
little bit of leeway but that's just me
what do you mean NBC News owned by GE
which is a defense contractor might have
a reason to lie about Walters i right
right do you think you should be
punished her what do you think uh I
think if this is an isolated instance
like I do think there's a chance that
you know they say the fog of war not
that he was really in war but he was in
a war zone and I think there's a chance
that maybe some other helicopter Larry
Clinton did something like this once
where she said she got out of a plane
somewhere I forgetting it was under the
hail of gunfire and then that turned out
not to be true so politicians all lie
and they don't know they sort of don't
know the difference between lying and
the truth so now this guy's ain't know
the difference come on yeah do they go
to different yeah they know I guess they
really do so I firing it if they find
out more of these if they if there's one
more like similar then it's like yeah
we've got a case but one thing that he
got a little like his ego just went a
little nuts yeah I don't think yeah it's
definitely an ego thing but I mean like
you said politicians do it all the time
it isn't that worse my god wouldn't know
well have you been totally truthful for
this entire segment this entire segment
I think I've been able to pull it off I
too have been totally truth tell us your
truthful feelings in the comments write
em alone